jurassic park iii probablement le plus
décrié des films de la saga était-il en
avance sur son temps l'une des scènes
les plus critiqués du film jurassic park
iii c'est la scène où alan grant utilise
la chambre de résonance du vélociraptor
pour se sauver de ses prédateurs féroces
et bien l'existence de cette chambre de
résonance dans ce film est visionnaire
un au moins deux égards la première
c'est que cette chambre de résonance est
imprimé en 3d elle est imprimée en 3d
par billy lors de la scène sur le site
de fouilles ou billy souffle dedans pour
la première fois rappelant le bruit des
vélociraptors à alan grant cette
imprimante 3d elle est toute en images
de synthèse évidemment parce qu'à
l'époque c'était un peu de la science
fiction a pris la pression 3d alors
l'impression 3d existe déjà depuis
longtemps au moment de jurassic park iii
qui date de 2001 mais son utilisation
quasi quotidienne n'est que très très
très récente et à l'époque c'était très
difficile de trouver une imprimante 3d
une véritable imprimante 3d surtout une
avec un grain aussi fins que celles
qu'ils utilisent dans le film d'où
l'utilisation d'effets numériques pour
vous dire un film avec un budget
hollywoodien a préféré recréer une
imprimante 3d en images de synthèse
plutôt que d'en acheter une vraie c'est
vous dire si à l'époque c'était pas
banal une imprimante 3d donc le film
jurassic park iii anticipe l'utilisation
systématique des imprimantes 3d en
recherche paléontologique de plus de 15
ans donc déjà ça c'est remarquable mais
en plus il faut voir ce qu'ils impriment
en 3d ce qu'ils impriment en 3d c'est
une chambre de résonance d'un
vélociraptor et cette chambre de
résonance d'un vélo si un temps ils
l'ont obtenu grant nous le dit durant
son discours ils l'ont obtenue grâce à
un scanner donc ce qu'on appelle un site
is khan en anglais ou ce qu'on appelle
de la tomographie 3d en français c'est
basiquement de l'imagerie médicale
appliquée à la paléontologie voilà on
utilise des rayons x pour voir au
travers de la roche et au travers des
fossiles pour voir ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur des fossiles notamment la
boîte crânienne est aussi ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur de la cavité nasale
et ce qu'ils trouvent dans jurassic park
iii à l'intérieur de la cavité nasale
c'est un organe complexe une chambre de
résonance de velociraptor eh bien avec
cet élément qui en 2001 la sortie du
film nous paraissent complètement fou
jurassic park iii en fait anticipé les
recherches d'un paléontologue d'un
véritable paléontologues qui s'appelle
larry witt moeurs et dont l'équipe a
étudié des crânes de dinosaures en
utilisant des sites is khan des scanners
médicaux justement et ils ont découvert
non pas chez velociraptor mais chez
d'autres dinosaures les ankylose or et
bien que dans leur nez se cacher un
organe extrêmement complexe des
circonvolutions du système nasale dont
larry witt moeurs et son équipe ont fait
l'hypothèse qu'il pouvait servir à
produire des sons et ça c'était en 2008
c'est seulement sept ans après jurassic
park iii et l'année suivante en 2009 la
même équipe à réétudier de nouveaux
dinosaures et notamment de nouveau en
kilos d'or et ils ont affiné leurs
hypothèses en déterminant que ces
circonvolutions nasale serait de très
mauvaises chambre de résonance par
contre il pourrait s'agir d'un très très
bon système d'échangeurs thermiques donc
en réalité ce serait un système si vous
voulez qu'ils serviraient à refroidir le
cerveau de ces dinosaures et non pas à
produire des sons et cela n'est pas sans
rappeler les cornes et les crêtes des
dinosaures lambé aux origines et et
autres hadrons or tel que parra the role
of us qui était creusé à l'intérieur
desquels les conduit naseaux passait
faisait un long détour et justement
l'équipe de larry witt meurt une fois de
plus à étudier ces lambé aux rennais et
a déterminé que l'oreille interne des
landes et aux origines et edéa droz or
en général était plus adaptée à
l'audition des basses fréquences basses
fréquences qui on pense pouvait être
produite grâce à ces circonvolutions
naseaux donc même si chez les ankylose
or ça servait peut-être pas de chambre
de résonance chez les lambert aux
origines et les adh rose or ça reste
encore l'hypothèse qu'ils établissent
que ses prolongements des circuits
naseaux servait à produire des sons de
très basse fréquence pour communiquer et
la grande question c'est est-ce qu'une
telle chambre de résonance existe
effectivement chez les velociraptor
alors le crâne qu'il nous montre dans le
film n'est pas un vrai crâne de
velociraptor qui a été scannée ils n'ont
pas poussé le vice à ce point là le
crâne qu'on voit dans le film a été
probablement complètement recréé en 3d
ce n'est ni un crâne de velociraptor ni
même un crâne de démo ni qc certainement
inspiré d'un crâne de démonique us mais
ce n'est pas un crâne de dénommer cus et
la vérité bien c'est qu'on n'en sais
rien parce que jamais personne n'a
étudié cavité nasale des velociraptor
avec un site is khan l'année dernière en
2020 il y a eu la première étude d'un
fragment de crâne de velociraptor avec
un site is khan il s'agissait de la
boîte crânienne donc les chercheurs ont
pu étudier l'oreille interne et une
partie du cerveau à savoir le cervelet
ainsi que les lobes flow cullers du
cervelet par contre ils n'ont pas
scannés la partie antérieure du crâne
donc la partie nasale donc on n'est pas
sûr à l'heure actuelle de ce que
contient la cavité nasale des
velociraptor mais on sait d'après
l'étude d'autres dinosaures théropodes
d'autres études conduites par l'équipe
de larry witt moeurs que les dinosaures
théropodes posséder des sacs aérien dans
le nez qui devait aussi servir de
chambre de résonance ainsi que
d'échangeurs thermiques qui faisait un
système de refroidissement pour le
cerveau donc jurassic park iii était
tellement en avance sur son temps qu'ils
ont même anticiper une future étude du
museau des velociraptor qui n'a pas
encore eu lieu à l'heure où je vous
parle en 2021 et une telle découverte
sera permise par l'utilisation de rayons
x qui permettront de voir à travers la
roche qui remplit la cavité nasale des
fossiles de velociraptor parce que comme
le dit si bien alan grant c'est dans la
roche que les véritables savant fond de
vraies découvertes